it is the uncertainty of some high
school sports a lack of bus
transportation to after school practice
may force some sports to cancel their
season as if these kids haven't been
through enough can you imagine and mary
jane bezos shares a teacher's
frustration at rancho high school
students and teachers at rancho high
school in the north valley are left
scrambling for options after the clark
county school district announced buses
will not be provided for all after
school practices in the county and will
only provide buses to games only heather
dancer is a teacher at rancho high
school watching this issue unfold
students of lower socioeconomic don't
have the means after school to have a
brand new car or a mom and a minivan
sitting there waiting to take them to
the pools and so a lot of coaches at the
schools that are what we consider title
one are considering or have already made
the decision to cancel the swim season
dancer speculates a number of reasons
for the district's decision including
bus driver shortages and budget issues
and so when they made the statement they
thought they were making an equality
statement by saying well we're not just
picking and choosing what schools will
or won't get buses nobody gets buses
what they don't understand is the equity
that just got lost because like i said a
lot of higher end schools are able to
provide that transportation in several
different ways with resources and then
lower income schools cannot dancer says
while teachers aren't allowed to provide
rides for students they are exploring
other alternatives it's how we resolved
it and a bust like you said is a is a
lot of money and there's some swim teams
that probably will be able to swing this
believe it or not and ours
we'll be lucky if we find free city bus
passes for our students at rancho
reporting from bruce and owens mary june
balliazza live local now